Okay, here is
the unconventional way that I mop my floors.
You're gonna need a full size bath towel.
So what I like to do is
whenever a bath towel start getting thin and just, like,
old and warm,
they retire
and they become my cleaning towels.
And then I'm gonna fill up my kitchen sink.
I just love using my sink because it's really deep,
it's really big.
It's perfect for this.
And I do make sure that I steam and sanitize it
every time I'm done cleaning.
You can use a bucket if you have one that's big enough.
So I'm gonna fill it with really warm water,
and then I'm also going to add a little bit of dawn.
Sometimes I'll use other things, like.
I love this method,
squirt and mop.
I also love this product.
I ran out of it,
but anyway, today we're gonna do Dawn.
And then you take it
and you pluck it down on the ground and step on it,
and you start mopping.
So when I'm doing it,
I'll do just, like,
a little area,
and then I'll actually flip it over,
do another little area,
and then I'll go ring it out. And, um,
after I run it out twice,
I'll refresh the water.
So it really kind of depends on how, like,
big your house is or how dirty your house is.
I have two kids,
so my house does get messy a lot.
And I do mop A lot.
And every two weeks or so,
I'll do my floor trifecta,
where I will sweep the.
Sweep everything,
and then I will mop everything with the towel,
and then I will use my steamer and steam everything
just to make sure it is nice and clean.
So, yeah, that's how I mop my floors.
That's how my mom taught me to do.
That's how my grandma did it.
And I thought it was interesting to see.
Probably half the people in my comments of
the original video told me that they did the same thing
and that their mom did the same thing,
and the other half had never seen it done before,
and it was totally shocking to them.
So kind of an interesting thing.
I've tried normal mops.
I've tried swiffers.
I've tried all of those things.
I just feel like they kind of gross me out
just hanging there.
This way, when I'm done mopping,
I just throw my towel into the washing machine,
and it just feels fresh and clean. Um,
and it works.